la route du rhum mais elle s'est bien
terminée sans avatar est sûrement pas en
cale sèche pour le gagnant laurent
bourgnon mais aussi pour son second paul
vatine arriver trois heures plus tard
christophe duchiron frédéric bazille
reportage à la guadeloupe
accueilli par les lumières de la ville
au son des cornes de brume paul vatine
arrive à prendre encore quelques mètres
et le navigateur va rompre avec quatorze
jours de solitude
juste après l'arrivée la meute des
journalistes ni par vous rattraper
alors il faut parler et encore parlé
la foule est là aussi enthousiaste faut
rendre hommage à paul vatine un gars de
normandie devenu marin un gap à pierre
qu'on appelle paulo un homme de
tempérament qui a bataillé dur avec
laurent bourgnon
batigne très heureux que vous voyez est
complet par des braqueurs qui
n'accueille paul 28 second placement
attribue aussi la grandeur de la route
du rhum cette transat de montceau avec
cette bagarre au plus haut niveau avec
laurent bourgnon il fallait un duel il
fallait pas un cavalier seul
on a été deux dans cette course est
aussi un bon oeil par une bonne époque
pense que tout ça fait que la route du
rhum 94 ne sera pas mort du roi fahd des
spectateurs dans leur arbre perché
attendre quelque chose
un caméraman à moustache qui fait la dj
un monsieur à chapeau un peu nerveux des
jumelles à l'appareil photo bref on
s'impatiente
hier après midi sur le quai du port il
n'y a pas le feu semble dire laurent
bourgnon pointe à pitre me voici
j'arrive et je gagne et je bats le
record de florence arthaud il est temps
désormais démarrer un bateau qui vient
de passer 14 ans sur les mers attention
le petit oiseau va sortir
c'est laurent bourgnon qui profite de
ses derniers instants de calme après
c'est plus musclée du corps à corps avec
la preuve après c'est plus exotiques
laurent burelle arrivée il veut savourer
m
les vacances
hier soir avec deux premiers se raconte
des histoires de marins il ne s'était
pas vu depuis 14 jours
le rallye automobile de grande